no I'm not saying I get bored of being a
mother I'll get bored of the routine I
get your point you want your own
identity and your own self it's not even
that I just want to be able to I just
don't want to be sitting at home okay
wake up at six yeah
I don't think having children is like
you how could you get bored of having
your children I'm not saying you're not
you're missing to everyone I'm saying
I'm not saying I'm getting bored of
having my children I'll get bored what
do you need to get away you don't have
to do the same thing with me yeah but
who said you have to make it the same
but Terry he's not the same okay maybe
because of the lifestyle that I live so
the job that I do is no days the same so
nothing is the same whereas if you're
staying at home I feel like it'll just
be it just wouldn't suit me